I am indeed with Ray Robson back-to-back
victory for you Ray and a big one
against uh Wesley what are your initial
feelings right now yeah I'm
feel like I would expect to be like more
joyous I'm very happy but yeah I'm a
little bit surprised I guess how well
the game went for me uh I've played
Wesley many many times I think probably
our last like
I don't know eight games or something
have been draws usually when I'm I've
been white many times and I usually get
zero Advantage I just have to
immediately make a draw so today went a
lot differently we were looking at your
head to head and I think he was leading
two victories to a one and eight draws
so it was very very competitive within
between YouTube and you guys know each
other from college days how would you
assess Wesley as a trustler what are his
strengths weaknesses
um well he's give us some insights
obviously he's he's good at everything
he's a universal player I guess more
positional
um in general but obviously he can
attack
um yeah he studies a lot he reviews his
lines all the time
um but he probably wasn't expecting that
I would know this line that we had today
and he is he can be a concrete player if
he thinks the position is good even if
it looks risky he may just go for it
um so sometimes he might be susceptible
to attacks which I guess is uh did you
know this line uh the spawn sacrifice
yeah so I was it's not super common line
but fortunately I recently had reviewed
this line so uh I was pleasantly
surprised to see it
um and then you have to take take
um I believe yeah H3 is a interesting
move preventing Bishop G4 and after
Knight bd7
um I think Queen C2 okay apparently
there's one game but I think it hasn't
really been analyzed much the idea is
you're just delaying the development of
the bishop
um if white I played Bishop B2 I think
D5 is supposed to be the correct
response for black
or as keeping the bishop there one move
longer means the bishop might go to G5
in some lines I think here D5 just is
losing for black maybe bishop A3 or
something
in fact let's check that yes the engine
confirms Bishop to A3 or Bishop to G5
seem to be very very strong actually
Bishop to A3 root to E1 Rook to E7
that's it should be seven yeah or Bishop
he said that's a problem yeah yeah so B6
I remember is uh yeah a move and okay
Bishop B2 Bishop B7
um D5 yeah actually in this position
still so you are still within your
preparation at this point I mean I had
to analyzed this previously yeah
um and yeah basically I knew my idea is
if he plays something similar to what he
did in the game with the queen f8 then I
can go for G4 King H2 G5 and just attack
um
and that was basically all I knew so
yeah he played C6 here uh which I didn't
remember from my analysis so I was
hoping it would be a mistake apparently
it is apparently it is it is and
especially with the moves that you found
over the board take us through your
thought process at this point because
you only have one path and you have to
be extremely precise you thought for 18
minutes what were you thinking about
yeah I'm a little bit surprised there's
only one win here I mean it looks
overwhelming for example Rook G1 is a
very natural move as well
um yeah he can put the the queen on E7
in general I wasn't sure yet to give his
score for his King I mean
going back to CD I was
um immediately drawn to this idea of
Bishop H7 Bishop 5 where Bishop F5
immediately but Bishop H7 felt a little
bit better forced him onto the long
diagonal where my Bishop is and also his
King can't uh run away to the queen side
as quickly so this felt very natural but
um there are a couple of things so after
King h8 Bishop F5 I'm just starting to
take so 95 looks kind of forced F4 and
one option was Knight takes D4
yeah and now after Bishop F6 gf6 if
Black's King were back on G8 I assume
it's completely crushing even just Rook
G1 here I was uh took me a while to find
the way because Rook G1 I'm a Tempo down
so I wasn't sure if it was working
apparently it's still working but uh I
hadn't calculated deep enough to be sure
about that but then I noticed I have
Queen E2 and he doesn't have Queen H6
ever because Knight F7 and FG Queen H5
is just made so once I noticed this
queen queen into Queen H5 is always
working
um I became very happy so then I was
about to play this and then I realized
okay I should check Knight G6 one more
time after F4
Knight G6 and initially I intuitively
just felt completely winning but then
when I was calculating
I couldn't see like a clear win like if
I take on G6 F6 G6 Queen takes G6 I
thought he has Queen E8 and somehow he's
just holding so I could play after
Knight G6 Rook G1
which maybe is yeah okay apparently it's
also crushing but
I wasn't completely sure and then
I started calculating what I did in the
game Bishop F6 GF Knight F7 Queen M7
Bishop G6 and I saw okay I'm only done
one Pawn his King's completely open
g-files open Queen's gonna go with f2h4
F5 H5 and I didn't see any way he could
organize his pieces in time so I decided
this should just be winning and that's
when I played Bishop H7 Bishop 5 yep and
your intuition was definitely correct
because he's just one tempo of short
yeah so actually it's interesting after
Queen E7 if we could just yes back there
I thought the game is just over I mean I
thought Queen F2 was crushing um
but I just for some reason uh missed F5
which is the only try and then yeah
after Rook G1 okay I thought it's still
just completely game over but I missed
the Rook to G7 and his King somehow has
a shield and I can't attack and then I
became worried that somehow I've just
messed it up because it must have been I
knew I must have been winning
um but then I think yeah I was fortunate
this queen H5 so Queen H4 King G8 Queen
H5 and the point is if D takes C4
um Bishop H7 King f8 Rook takes F5 Rook
F7 and initially they only saw Queen H6
King 8 Bishop G6 but then he should give
checks and make a Perpetual or maybe
check maybe
um but after Rook F7 there
I moved yeah after 33 Rook F7 one move
back yeah I I noticed that Bishop G6
finally yeah so he doesn't have time to
take on C4 he has to go back and then CD
and E2 is covered E2 is covered and
still I had to find the Breakthrough but
then I realized I can do what I did in
the game just put the queen on H6 Rook
on G2 and then I'm always turning Bishop
F5 and he just he can't move any any
pieces um if he plays like Bishop B7 in
the final position Bishop takes F5 I
thought it's the simplistic Rook G7 and
then I take on D6 take on D5 and queen
comes back to G2 and
I'm gonna stop a piece so Ray
congratulations uh big victory for you
guys any questions yeah first of all
congratulations Ray you started with
five draws uh you can't you you couldn't
win a game and uh suddenly uh the clouds
parted the sun is shining what happened
oh I don't know yeah I'm very surprised
like obviously I was playing Hans
yesterday and then Wesley today so still
two super strong opponents and was
definitely was never expecting to get
two wins
um I don't know yesterday I think Hans
was just
um a bit over aggressive at the critical
moment and today uh I think today
obviously I got lucky that he played
into this very dangerous line which I
happened to study recently so yeah I
mean I played well both games but I
think I've been playing pretty well
throughout the tournament just uh maybe
my opponents gave me a few more chances
and uh yeah I was I was ready to pounce
yeah yes sir you you met Yasser actually
mentioned today that you live together
with uh Wesley and you played thousands
of games of blades like and do you think
you actually get something from uh
Wesley and his style while you were
playing all these games and uh did you
did you cooperate with him after you
stopped the college and uh later on
yeah I mean we worked a bit together
when we were at Webster but mostly it
was him you know he that's when he kind
of started to be really serious about
Chess and started his Ascension um so he
was studying all the time
um and I I was not at that point so
occasionally like I would join him and
analyze some things but mostly it was
just him on his own um as far as playing
with him if that helped me uh definitely
helped me a lot I would say that's
almost the only reason I improved
um when I was in college is just through
being around him playing against him
asking the questions about certain types
of positions I once I realized that he
was actually just a much better player
than me I started listing to what he was
saying and uh I think it changed the way
I thought about Chess so
um you know I think I went from 2600 to
about 26 50 at that time and I think
primarily that's just because of
learning from him wow that's really nice
I mean that's really impressive and
today you even managed to win uh I think
it even feels really good today okay
congratulations once again yeah very
nicely done indeed Ray you still got a
second half of a tournament to go but it
feels good to be doing it with a plus
two and undefeated escort let's just
jump in in